are you kidding me there's Doritos
liquor why is everybody getting into the
hard liquor
game what the
[__] hey
Doritos you're
disgusting
Doritos you're [__] absolutely
disgusting dude I've the last time I ate
Doritos was oh my God decades ago hey
Doritos to Rel nacho cheese flavored
alcoholic drink that tastes like crisps
hey
disgusting hey you lose
resign oh my God it's called
empirical that's the company they're
using okay look at it's got a it's got a
in the ad it's got a a drink on the
rocks with a Dorito chip over it like
it's a lime like on the thing just
disgusting
dude Doritos are you ever eat a Dorito
and you're just like do you ever eat a
Dorito and not think oh this is killing
me right now I don't I don't eat Doritos
but and not to say I don't I did eat a
brownie last night and ice cream and
fries and that's why my love handles
aren't going away
but no I ate those a few nights ago
sweetie you're not part of this when I
have you on as a guest be a guest but
don't be chiming in saying I ate six
Reese's peanut butter cups when that was
three nights before this not last night
Dorito's liquor why is everybody got to
having a liquor thing why does why like
I'm just going to throw names out there
I guarantee they have liquor companies
Mario Lopez there's [__] no way in
hell that he doesn't have a liquor
company or you know what I mean there's
[__] no way in
hell I bet Gary Oldman I bet he has a
[__] liquor and it's sold in like
France and and and you
know tequ Mary Mary Lopez and Oscar de
Hoya have a tequila together there you
go there you go I I knew I knew without
knowing because obviously they do why
does how much [__] drinking needs to
happen I don't even mean drinking
alcohol how many things do people need
to
drink I'm [__] satiated dude I drink
water and coffee that's all I
drink